check one two
check check
uh hi
my name is markiplier and welcome to the
mandela invasion now this is awfully
serendipitous
here's the definition of serendipity um
because i just did a video on analog
horror
and i don't think that this is by the
same person that did the uh the maple
county training video what is
what is that what is this big nose freak
doing over here who's a squidward-ass
person here with big ears anyway so this
is um
i don't really know what this is
[Music]
if you still lose here you will find
tips i don't need tips
find a flashlight it's hard to survive
in the dark make sure that the windows
are boarded up look around explore
remember even if you think you're safe
you are
wrong i think i'm safe right now am i
wrong
i have no idea
all right so
i wasn't ready to start the video by the
way i just want to point that out i was
i was
am i
i am recording right my mic is on
everything's good okay we're fine
all right i'm not going to the game now
let's see what you got mandela invasion
what the hell looks like my room but
different am i still in my house
no no no i've never been here before
hi
oh
okay
hi what the [ __ ] what can i turn i don't
know it's your tv man
god that's annoying
okay is this just a battle of wits here
press space to hide the flashlight okay
good what's this on hotkey okay
all right well i have a flashlight now
that's good
board up i don't have planks
okay
oh
okay i gotta go to the bathroom
whoa
oh
okay
all right
i see i wasn't i wasn't expecting this
i haven't seen
well i don't like that
well i know i i i don't want to go there
yes who is it
[Music]
i have a surprise for you
i got a surprise for you too when you
get in here but
you know it's gonna be a lot of punches
to the dick if you have a dick
which i'm still not sure how accurate
these replications are from the
alternates
why
hi
oh is it darker wait
oh no
okay all right
ah
okay
i don't want to go to the basement
i'd rather not i'd rather not okay i got
a lot of these
okay
everything's fine ah
why why
oh no
am i am i dead
oh
[Applause]
okay
i was really actually freaked out
and then it's
i'm embarrassed i'm embarrassed at how
much that got me for what that jump
scare was but you know i judge a game on
its atmosphere more than i do it's jump
scares so that's fine with me man i i
didn't warm up at all before i got it
[Music]
i don't know man so what i have to do is
i have to get the flashlight and then i
have to find where the planks are and
then i have to
board up the windows all before can i
please oh
oh no
oh
there's my flashlight
oh god
was that me or did that was that me did
i make a noise there
i don't want to go i'm a brave boy i'm a
bro
i'm not a brave boy i gotta go piss
myself okay all right um
okay so i'm not being speedy here
hi again
hello hi
i have a surprise for you
that's great you need to work on your
voice oh i can't open the door i don't
know why i want to but i can't open the
door
um
nope not there either
okay
okey-dokey
okay flashlight good very good
cable sure
garage sure
oh god oh god oh my god oh my god
oh my god oh my god
oh my god
okay
no
i see
oh hi oh hi
oh the lamb's belly is cut open you can
hear a heartbeat what do you want to do
slow down
hold on there
oh
why would i take the heart out of the
lamb
i thought that was gonna be like more
[Applause]
okay
so i have to be a lot faster than what
i'm doing currently which is not fast at
all
all right all right okay all right i'm
gonna stop being a little [ __ ] about
this and i'm actually gonna be proper
about what i'm doing go go go
go
what the hell is this looks like my room
but different go go wait oh it could be
here i'm guessing it's just random
come on come on
come on
oh damn it okay there's one in the
bathroom
damn it okay
wasting time there's one here there
everywhere there's nothing
oh my god
did i grab it i have no idea
okay that's what i needed okay um uh uh
get the heart
rip this heart out
oh planks planks planks planks planks i
can't carry more blanks please i'm very
strong okay fine okay
um oh electrical box
key
great
i want to leave thank you okay that
window board
okay
grab that grab this grab that grab this
okay there was one in the kitchen
okay
all right no i'm doing good
i think
i'm pretty sure
okay there was one in the hallway here
and there was one in my room
okay easy peasy easy peasy ease my peas
these my peas ease my peas and my peas
is ease
and my peas is ease boom done was there
one in the bathroom there might have
been one in the bathroom let me double
check
was it
can i board up the garage
no okay there was one in the bath there
was a i
was open
vent board up the vent
is there one in the attic
oh hi
oh
why
[Applause]
wake up
wake up wake up wake up
do not be afraid
i have
i am your true stay clear
i know everything about what makes you
human
i know what you love
okay
rule to myself
don't rip the hearts out of goats
and don't smear that on paintings all
right let's try that again shall we
let's um
not do that
okay nothing there
anything here nothing there let's go get
us a flashlight
okay that's good
that's good that's good let's go okay
flashlight that's what we needed
okay thank you
let's go yes grab that don't die the
temptation to grab the heart right out
of that thing is very strong but i shall
resist
because i am strong
here
there there
there no come on move move move move
your ass
down there
here
there there
up here in here right there slam bam i'm
gonna grab two more planks anyway just
because i can
there was nothing else in this room
right there's an electric box uh and
there was nothing in here oh cable
that's important
probably
i looked all in here i'm not hungry
can't do anything with that
okay
so
can i board up a door
who's there oh
[Music]
what the [ __ ] is that oh
what why can't i board that up
not that it would do anything really i
guess but
okay okay
okay okay we're fine everything's good
everything's good everything is good
no
okay
no there must be something to find here
don't smear blood on that
why what
what is it
what is that
oh
no
no no no no no no no no no no
you stop that now
okay what else can i do it's 1am so time
is moved
it was 12 before
oh wait
i lose
why lose what in the hell
am i just not supposed to go
there
ever all right okay
okay i'm just gonna gun it
and then i'm gonna stay
somewhere where i can be safe
that's what i'm gonna do
either
i don't know what i'm doing
i don't know why i'm here oh that's
convenient
okay uh
this that take take
board up
take
take take
go go
super speed i just need to make sure
that i'm in a place where i can go to
the garage because that definitely seems
like if that garage i'm not supposed to
be here i'm doing the hallway that
definitely seems like
if
that opens i'm dead
so i'm just not gonna let that happen
why were you here
boarding it up didn't seem to do
anything for me maybe i gotta
turn that off
regularly i gotta try to turn it off you
know every so often maybe
i don't know i think i got everything
boarded up
something about that vent cover i don't
remember there being any kind of tool
was there a tool did i i didn't search
the kitchen today
[Music]
there's a cable all right that's good
is that something i can use
i'm very hungry
okay it's got to be some kind of
clickable
that i have not seen
why were you like this i'm just gonna
turn this off like once an hour
just to be safe
right
i imagine that just going to random
rooms is probably going to give you
killed and what are you about
why was the whole
oh god oh god oh god
okay so what what is the whole deal
about all of this baloney what's with
this lamb
maybe there's something else i could do
with it why would i do this
i can't do anything with that
why
what was that
what is that
what is that is that you in here
oh god oh god yeah what that must or why
where's the hey
why
what did i do
what did i what did i do find a
flashlight make sure that the windows
are boarded up look around explore even
if you think you're safe you're wrong
restoring the power is a good idea
hide flashlight there must be moment
it's me walking around with a flashlight
there must be some monster that thing
that doesn't like the light so i need to
turn it off really quickly that's what
it must be
so i need to not have that on all the
time and it's probably that audio cue
that weird what did i just get i have no
idea i was going to wig
uh
that's what means that that thing's
around that's my guess anyway
i could be very wrong i'll talk to you
in a bit
okay that i need the flashlight
yeah yeah yeah there it is got last
place i look of course
okay i got that hello goat and then i'm
walking around the flashlight no i
needed it exactly in this moment
let me go ahead and unlock this okay
and hide the flashlight last one's in my
room
yes bam done okay cool just gonna grab
two more just in case
just in case hide the flashlight
[Music]
in the garage i would assume that there
would be
no
okay
so that's one thing that i have to
manage there must be something else
that i need to
manage right
i don't know
like it wasn't a quiet sound
[Music]
no it's not here it's the vent
something about the vent what about the
vent
what no
no no
oh my god okay so that's it
that's it oh my god oh my god oh my god
hurry hurry hurry no no no no no no no
so that's it
i just didn't realize it before
i see now
so there's a vent cover was there
anything else here
that needed my attention there's a tv
here but i'm not 100 sure about that
oh
yeah
get it back in there
i hear you
there's got to be like a third one i
would think
maybe
right
oh
i hear you
oh come on
no
okay so far so good so maybe it wasn't
me walking around with the flashlight
oh god
okay bye
oh god oh god oh god oh god oh god oh
god oh god oh god oh god oh god oh god
no
i don't think it was me rocking around
the flashlight right must've been
again
same seas
same z's
no thank you
why do i feel like there's something i'm
missing
probably because it's a horror game and
everything's trying to kill me and i get
that and i understand that but there's
something that i'm missing here
i feel it can't just be running between
these two places something is gonna kill
me
it's gotta be something
i don't like it up here
okay i hear that
oh god not at the same time wait which
one do i go to first oh god oh god oh
god okay and uh go go go
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh my god no please tell me i got that
i hope i did
oh god it is they'd love going at the
same time
that guy
charging up his chuckle engine
no no no no no no
this is stressful
i'm just not going in my room and i know
that's probably a mistake is gonna lead
to my demise
but
you know
same time again
but you first
you always start opening before
and perfect time good good good good
excellent excellent excellent actually
it really does just seem to be these two
i'm waiting for the sound to finish
every time on the
5am that's good
but i do feel like there's got to be
something else here
there has to be
right there has to be
i guess why would there be right
oh god hurry up hurry up hurry up oh my
god oh my god go go go go go go oh my
god
[Applause]
[Music]
man if this is all it takes to stop the
alternates
i'm doing pretty good
5 a.m it's got to be almost 6. and i've
got to assume that this this nightmare
ends at 6. that's what i have to assume
i have to
okay
come on six no really not no i can't
leave
okay
you can see how i assumed that it might
did i close it i thought i closed it
shut it on his fingers as he was trying
to reach under the door
not this time mr chucklemeister
not this time giggles
so it's not six am is it seven am
8 am
no
oh what's that what is with the time is
being what is what is oh what
wait no don't do that i'm
you
what what is happening
what well i i don't understand dude i
win
can anybody win is this a no winner
situation is everybody a loser in this
world
have the altar isn't it taken over my
brain
there's a butthole here is it getting
brighter
i can't tell i feel like it's getting
brighter but i feel like i'm a frog in a
pot of slowly boiling water and i can't
tell the temperature differential or i'm
an idiot and it's not changing at all
am i
what
uh
what is that
eject
what
did i win
did i lose
what happened did i monkey did it get
bogged
[Music]
what i feel like that wasn't everything
i feel like i didn't do it
i don't know
give me your heart and yarg
i know i haven't boarded up the windows
but that's because i'm not
i'm just confused so i don't know why
i would bother
oh my god oh my god hi
okay well that that opens hi i don't
know how me boarding that up stop that
from happening but hello welcome to my
room come on in let me turn the tv off
for you
oh we're playing this game again okay
well that's weird
i don't know what's happening
oh god what is that oh
oh that the power's going out
oh
i can repair it
[Music]
did i need to board up the windows
heart taken out of a lamb a lamb's heart
great
all right so anyway i think this is the
end uh
lixian if you can find any other ending
to this game
put it here
and credit whoever you find actually no
i'm gonna i'm gonna look this up because
i wanna know if i
i wanna know what the hell i did wrong
two new alternates two new endings new
mechanic what do you mean two new
alternates
what are you talking about okay anyway i
can't find it so i'll put a link to this
game in the description below if you
guys want to play for yourself and try
to find some other
ending
because apparently there's more than one
but uh
i have no idea so thank you everybody so
much for watching this has been the
mandela invasion
keep your doors shut
and vent covers
and windows
and garages
i think i hear it opening now
you better go check on that
don't worry
i'll be here
waiting
[Music]
you